minimum wage 15 bucks an hour looks like
they're forcing it through
with the 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
and you can't vote for it i can't vote
for this the benefit
of a political party winning presidency
senate and house and
the other side has to pay a price but i
just want to give you a couple stats and
i'll make my case due to small business
owners and individuals
uh do you know what's the highest
country that pays the most minimum wage
in the world
australia you know what it is uh 1260.
you know australia is known to be a
socialist country do you know the next
one is france at 12 10 then germany 1180
then netherlands 11 bucks uk canada
south korea japan then it's u.s
you know what russia's minimum wage is
2.40
you know what china's minimum wage is
you do not want to know china's minimum
wage by the way norway
doesn't have a minimum wage there's a
lot of countries that don't have a
minimum wage they just trust the fact
that the business owner is going to take
care of the employee
and they trust the fact that the
employee's going to work so hard to
create high value in a marketplace so
they're paying more
they don't say the government needs to
come and do what they do so if a lot of
these countries in the top five minimum
wage
are higher than us and we're about to be
number one at 15 bucks
they're socialists and now you beat all
the countries around the world
and minimum wage and their socialists
what does that make america
i don't know but you put the two
together it is what it is
so what does the minimum wage really do
and then how does this apply
to motivation monday let me get right
into it so number one
adam and i are sitting here talking and
says pat i said i feel
so bad for these small business owners
says pat why do you feel so bad for a
small business so i don't feel bad for a
small business owner
he said they know what they were doing
when they got into business that's not
like it's anyone's fault they knew they
were going to do business so if they go
out of business because of a minimum
wage that's their fault
i said uh-huh great point let me make my
case on why i disagree with you says
what is it
i said see if you and i were to get into
a fight and it's a big fight it's a
fight we're gonna do it on youtube
adam saw stick against patrick with
david okay here's the rules and
guidelines
it's boxing only unless you say adam
you're a better boxer than me you're an
eight i'm a six and a half okay
so you know as long as you take care of
your body your health
your diet your stamina you can last the
whole you know 10 rounds 12 rounds
you're going to beat me because you're a
better boxer better defender great i
said but i'm a ridiculous kickboxer my
kick is an eight you don't even kick
you have no clue how to kick you're two
i said imagine five minutes before the
fight starts they say
new rule being added to the fight we can
officially have
kicks in the fight i said who wins that
fight
you do is that fair to you no it's not
that's not fair to me i said exactly
that's what happened to small business
owners
small business owners have to worry
about improving their company improving
their product taking care of their
employees taking care of their customers
making sure they have money making sure
they're working on making sure they're
improving
but they can't do nothing about
government laws
these government laws are a form of
bullying
that put small business owners out of
business so how do they put small
business owners out of business
a recent study came out just a few days
ago that showed
if they raised minimum wage for 15 bucks
by the way this study is by cbo
which is not democrat or republican it's
just they come up with studies here's
the reports
if they raise minimum wage to 15 bucks
1.4 million people in america lose the
job
1.4 million people in america lose their
jobs and what does that mean if 1.4
million people lose their jobs here's
what it means
walmart say i have a market patrick's
market across the street is walmart the
only product i beat walmart in is milk i
sell milk for 3.49
walmart sells it for 359 that's my way
of getting 600 customers and families
that come to me
because we go to pbd's or patrick's
market because his milk is 10 cents
cheaper than who walmart
then all of a sudden they announce
minimum wage is 15 bucks
who do you think can afford to pay 15
bucks in our minimum wage and who can't
walmart can i cannot if i now have to
pay 15 bucks and i have to raise my
price of my milk from 349 to 429.
he can stay 359. how long until i go out
of business
how long until my 600 customers who love
me and say pat i got to tell you i love
you i love your jokes you're funny
you're so good to us
and i find him go to walmart and i sit
in front of walmart and i see all my
customers going there
how do you think i feel how can i win
them over i can't win them over i can't
sell it for 3.49
i have to close business you know who
celebrates walmart walmart says
bam thank you so much for raising
minimum wage we don't even have to put
these guys out of business
you're doing it for us you're so
wonderful all the politicians in dc
we love you right that's basically that
can go
an hour telling you different you know
analogies
numbers data for you to see okay that
makes sense now let's talk about the
other side
you know was the last time i got paid
minimum wage i was 14 or 15 or 16 years
old working for haagen-dazs
making ridiculous banana splits okay or
sorbet in a sugar cone or a waffle cone
or a little cup or
you know sundaes is what i made right
what was the value of my
pbd in a marketplace in 1994.
you know what probably around 1993 you
know i was probably worth
325 an hour or 375 an hour it's probably
what i was worth
okay then after uh
working at hagenas i get a job at bob's
big boy 5 15 an hour i was like man i'm
making it then i went to burger king
and i got 40 hours because bob's big boy
wouldn't give me 40 hours a week only
give me 20 hours a week
and then i never even thought about
minimum wage all i thought about is how
to increase my market value
look there's a place for unemployment
benefits 100
there's a place for you know some of
these uh
protection in case something happens to
you of course there's a place for all of
that
but leaning on that and on the
government your parents
what do you think about when a 25 year
old still living with his parents or 30
year old living with parents and parents
are taking care of them financially
what do you call that person so what do
you call a 30 35 year old that's relying
on the government to raise the minimum
wage for them
what's the difference between a name you
gave for either or what is it
well no that's different because no
there is no difference
it just means you're not increasing your
value in the marketplace now remember
i'm not talking about disabilities
and i'm not i'm not talking about all
that other stuff although i'm also not
talking about oh everybody has
mental issues or health issues i'm not
discounting that i get it
i know what it is to be going through
challenging times but can we use that on
every single person
i understand a small percentage of
america i understand small percentage
but that number keeps increasing
every time somebody's going through
tough times saying you don't know what
i'm going through stress wise
i'm sorry we're all under stress i got
three babies one on the way
family few businesses to run
people to support board to report to my
own health to take care of my
personal life trying to please my family
trying to take care of them
stress is there for all of us everybody
has some sort of stress some higher some
lower but to rely on
an institution your parents the
government
to support you and rely on you
increasing your wage
i don't know uh i would much rather rely
on my industry you know my effort my
desire to work to increase
my value in the marketplace
when i go to sleep at night i say okay
i'm getting paid what i'm worth and the
market is going to pay me
55 000 an hour 26 bucks a 55 000
a year which is what 26 bucks an hour
market's going to pay me 50 bucks an
hour which is what six figures
mark is going to pay me a hundred bucks
an hour which is what two hundred
thousand dollar income
market's going to pay me 500 bucks an
hour which is what a million dollar your
income
more than 500 000 people filed their
taxes last year that made over a million
dollars
the market pays if you and i
increase the market value not if
the government increases the minimum
wage so what is the right minimum wage
number
if they can make 15 is it 25 is it 35
why don't make it 50. why don't we make
100 bucks an hour for everybody
what do we come up with that money what
happens to everything in the marketplace
do gas prices go to four bucks five
bucks 10 bucks 20 bucks 30 bucks
do you want that to happen you know what
i'm saying so all of a sudden you're
depleting your savings so
again focus on increasing your market
value
and the next time somebody's trying to
sell you on the concept of minimum wage
have a better argument because we need
more people to understand the basics
of what happens if we raise the minimum
wage the way we have
and we make it highest highest in the
world we have the highest minimum wage
in the world now it's not something to
be proud of
when we're in debt the most in the world
those two don't go together
if you have the most debt in your family
do you go buy
a lexus or a porsche or a mercedes no
you go pay off your debt the numbers
don't make sense
and um we need more younger people
and uh folks to start having these types
of conversations so other people say
this makes sense to me anyways having
said that
the video i would recommend you watching
is a video i did about a year ago on
minimum wage it's
very very detailed if you've never seen
that click over here to watch the video
and having said that have a great week
everybody take care bye